desde los hospitales ucranianos los
médicos dan la voz de alarma niños
heridos a veces muertos y a menudo
traumatizados como los de natalia a
refugiados en el metro de quien el
soldado dijo corre rápido daba mucho
miedo
el más pequeño de mis hijos corría y
gritaba más rápido más rápido nos están
disparando no vamos a sobrevivir y
vinimos aquí ahora mi hijo tiene miedo
de salir yo era todo el tiempo mamá de
noche no mi hijo mayor grito en la noche
y mamá protegí ticas muchos de estos
niños se ven obligados a abandonar
ucrania en condiciones difíciles varios
días en la carretera y horas de caminata
antes de poder llegar a un lugar seguro
en el camino los equipos de unicef
intentan brindar lo necesario a las
familias que se dirigen al exilio
lo primero es el tratamiento de los
traumas de los niños es imprescindible
hacerlo inmediatamente tenemos
psicólogos que están acostumbrados a
este tipo de situaciones y que crean
condiciones de protección las zonas de
juego para los niños y también hay
distribuciones de agua y comida y
pañales que los pañales son varios
imagínense tres días de viaje en coche
sin pañales y con bebés se necesitan dos
citas y cuantos más niños tengamos en la
carretera más tendremos que cuidar este
aspecto tan importante ese aspecto se
apostó rumanía moldavia polonia hungría
eslovaquia y república checa- son países
donde estas jóvenes víctimas de la
guerra intentan encontrar refugio se
calcula que más de la mitad del millón y
medio de ucranianos en el exilio serían
niños unicef hizo un llamado a las
donaciones el jueves de 400 millones de
euros